bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouvel épisode d'un geste pour
la planète
si je vous dis industries chimiques
j'imagine que vous pensez à plein de
polluants super flippant à des rivières
vert fluo deraa trois têtes voir des
tortues balèze en arts martiaux mais
vous vous dites aussi que l'industrie
chimique
on en a besoin au quotidien pour créer
des médicaments des polymères des sacs
plastiques
euh non ça à boeufs bref c'est compliqué
de s'en passer
heureusement il existe maintenant une
chimie d'un genre nouveau qu'on appelle
verte
les chercheurs ont mis au point des
technologies qui permettent de créer des
produits synthétiques qui non seulement
nous rejoindre plus de nouvelles
pollutions mais en plus font disparaître
la pollution déjà existantes
[Musique]
ne pas polluer davantage ce brillant
mais dé polluer notre planète c'est
mieux parce que ça fait des décennies
que notre industrie l'âge dans la nature
des métaux lourds qui contaminent les
sols mais aussi les rivières ou encore
les nappes phréatiques pour les
détoxifier de manière écolo les
chercheurs du cnrs propose d'utiliser
des plantes
vous savez ce truc qu'on tue quand on
pollue des jardins filtrants permettent
en effet de purifier les eaux et
sédiments chargés de déchets pour
découvrir ça suivez-nous dans la
bioferme phytorestore ici on peut
purifier plusieurs types de boue comme
celle de la fosse septique ou encore les
boues industrielles contenant pléthore
de métaux lourds ou elle y met tous
comme disent nos amis anglophones
alors non non rien à voir avec la
musique ici lourd signifie surtout
toxiques
tout ça grâce aux racines des plantes
qui ont plus d'un tour dans leur sac
pour comprendre comment elles réagissent
face aux différents métaux lourds il va
nous falloir une technologie de pointe
les scientifiques doivent d'abord
prélever des échantillons
puis on les congèle en vitesse pour
figer les éléments qui s'y trouvent
et enfin on envoie la flotte se faire
scruté sous un rayon x pour révéler
comment les racines réagissent face aux
métaux à l'échelle microscopique
on constate alors que quand le taux de
cuivre et bah il est perçu comme un
micro nutriments la plante va donc le
capter à l'intérieur de sa sève brute et
l'envoyer vers ses feuilles pour en
nourrir la croissance
on a donc affaire à des plantes qui
mangent du métal ce qui pour le coup est
très longtemps
mais quand la plante est dans un endroit
trop polluée elle va résister à la
pollution en faisant appel à ses
mycorhizes les mycorhizes sondés
champignon filamenteux qui se forme sur
les racines
ils ont plein de fonctions par exemple
ils augmentent le réseau des racines
ce qui permet à la plante de croître en
profitant de plus de nutriments
ce qui intéressait scientifique c'est
qu'ils peuvent aussi servir de pièges
pour les métaux lourds
quand ils sont présents en trop grande
quantité au goût de la plante les
mycorhizes mans alors précipité le métal
et l'immobiliser pour créer une bulle
scène autour des racines principales
dans cette ferme dépolluantes
une fois que les métaux ont été
concentrés et on perd coulé à la base
des bassins ils sont envoyés dans des
filtres de piégeage l'élément clé de ces
filtres 100% naturel ce sont les tourbe
mais attention toutes les tours ne se
ressemblent pas il en existe différents
types qui vont plus ou moins bien match
et avec les métaux que l'on cherche à
éliminer alors tourbe de sphaigne à du
lourd sur kindle aux baleines on a hâte
en basse tous du 82 il a l'air d'avoir
du plomb dans la tête
j'adore et toi of mbas mois next next à
mercure du 69 ou celui là fait monter la
température
et ça marche très bien à la fin du
piégeage 98% des métaux sont tombés dans
les mailles du filet ces méthodes écolo
présente un autre avantage non
négligeable
elles sont économiques aujourd'hui en
france pour dépolluer une tonne de vue
industriel
il faut débourser 300 euros un prix
prohibitif pour tous les pays en voie de
développement qui ne peuvent tout
simplement pas traiter leurs déchets
alors qu'avec les méthodes de la
bioferme le prix de l'assainissement des
boues industrielles tombe à 2 euros la
tonne
de quoi donner les moyens aux pays les
plus défavorisés de ne pas être aussi
les plus pollués et de convaincre au
passage les pays les plus riches que ça
vaut le coup puisque visiblement
l'argument écologique ne suffit pas
owens est parfait non mais même à 2
euros la tonne avec toutes les saletés
qui traînent un peu partout dans le
monde où ça va chiffrer sévère mais
revenons à notre belle vieille francs
à la france ses plaines ses montagnes
ses mines de zinc abandonné où plus rien
ne pousse à cause de la pollution
nos chercheurs n'allait pas laisser ce
problème sans solution
il est désormais possible avec des
méthodes toutes douces de dépolluer les
sols et les eaux des anciens sites
d'extraction minière qui deviendront
peut-être bientôt de beaux espaces
boisés dont les enfants pourront
déguster la délicieuse bout évidemment
ces seules ultra polluer ne laisse
aucune chance aux plantes que nous avons
vu tout à l'heure et à leurs amis les
mycorhizes pour ces zones il existe des
supers plantes capables de survivre à la
présence de très forte teneur en métaux
mais ce n'est pas tout elles sont
également capables de les capter pour
les envoyer dans leurs feuilles
je vous présente la très jolie et très
costaude anti lead vulnéraire sur cette
ancienne mine d'extraction de zinc à
saint laurent le minier
la chimiste claude grison la cultive est
la chouchoute la scientifique estime
qu'avec cette plante le site sera
dépollué en moins de 50 ans et même si
ça prend du temps ça vaut le coup oh
mais qu'est ce qu'on s'en fiche
personne n'y va là-bas attentats pas une
maison d'architecte à 2 km du site toi
pas si pourquoi ben parce que les sols
sont pollués
du coup les plantes ne pousse plus et
comme les plantes ne pousse plus les
vents peuvent emporter de plus en plus
de morceaux du sol pollué qui t'arrive
en plein dans la tronche quand le vent
souffle au nord ouest la voilà et
surtout jacuzzi alors parlons jacuzzi un
bond qui qu'il faut donner du pognon là
pour les plantes qui bouffent le mercure
tout ça hein c'est bien beau tout ça
amène plantes dépolluantes dont les
feuilles sont donc polluer c'est comme
une relation toxique
il faut vite s'en débarrasser parce que
si on ne fait rien au bout d'un moment
elle va mourir pourrir et repos lui et
on sol il faut agir vite
heureusement il existe l'écho catalyse
un procédé génial qui permet de
valoriser ces déchets végétaux riches en
métaux lourds les particules métalliques
à l'intérieur des plantes pour lui sont
récupérés et avec les métaux extraits on
peut faire des catalyseurs les
catalyseurs sont des produits essentiels
en chimie ils servent à accélérer une
réaction pour construire une molécule
complexe à base d'éléments plus sommet
avec ces catalyseurs on peut synthétiser
des centaines de produits est rentré de
plain-pied dans la chimie verte la
chimie qui proposent des produits à la
fois synthétique et éco-responsable la
chimie qui crie du neuf avec du vieux
qui dépollue les deux millions de sites
qu'on à vouziers rien qu'en europe
en exploitant les mines de métal
puis le chili vertes qui polluent pas
l'air de la table mais trop lourd et
distribue dans ces messieurs valises
mettez la en terre offert à elle je ne
vois pas de rigueur c'est bon